andy uh as i seem to recall you're a
pretty big trivia guy isn't that right
i am pretty good at trivia i gotta say
oh you think you're pretty good
i do yeah well i too think i'm pretty
good at trivia
so uh i thought maybe we'd have a
friendly little
trivia competition on tonight's show
there's nothing friendly about trivia
conan
i know andy i know we're both pretty
competitive about this
it is on let's do it right now
all right here we go you ready i was
born
ready oh brian all right
which planet is the fourth furthest from
the sun
mars correct your turn andy
all right here we go in feudal japan
samurai roamed the land living by an
honor code called
the bushido what is the sixth
virtue of the bushido
what what are you talking about that's
so complicated
how am i supposed to know that the
answer is honor
conan i knew you wouldn't get it no
that's not fair give me a simpler
question
oh okay sure um french philosopher
renee descartes is well known for his
work on metaphysics
what object in many displays throughout
paris
first ignited descartes philosophies on
dualism
andy come on it's called trivia because
it's supposed to be
trivial stop giving me complicated
questions
all right fine here's a simple one um
what's att
5g easy why it's 5g that's fast reliable
and secure that's right conan it's not
complicated
all right here's one for you andy which
5g is fast reliable and secure
well att 5g of course that's right andy
it's not complicated
oh